so
settling in that's what eric spoelstra
was talking about
and tyler hiro the rookie and there's
his first playoff basket and
like you said do something opposite with
his left hand and that time able to be
creative
and finish off the glass indiana good
ball movement better hands by draggage
took it from mcconnell and hero the lob
and finished remember the bubble game he
was held five of 14
shooting he's answered that tonight
[Applause]
turned around by hero are you kidding me
both high number of assists jimmy
six on the season bam five and five and
change
olynyk inside off a great dime from
tyler hero
hero probing kicks it crowder steps
inside gives it right back
shot clock down to two heroes got to put
up a tough shot and he hits it
that's nasty what a rookie year he's
having in his first playoff
series big shot with the time
adebayo secures it plenty of time here
iguodala finds hero in the corner for
three it's good look at this
miscommunication
right here on defense and what happens
when that that's a loose play a broken
play like you called it and
how about iguodala brogdon can't finish
under four to play olynyk wide open
sneaking past the defense and it's an
eight-point heat lead
[Applause]
under 90 seconds left in the third heat
looking for some offense hero just
flicks
it up and it goes they're gonna need
some stops down here though now there's
only four and a half minutes to go
hero thought about it tiptoes into the
paint extends
right right-handed scoop and that was a
thing of beauty
stan your memories of this gentleman
well certainly a great coach
but i had the opportunity to work with
patrick ewing side draggage contested
three
no and look at adebayo
extra possession hero open
got it andre iguodala
16-year veteran gets the rebound tyler
hero off the bounce
three is good and miami leads by 10.
it's not just the fearlessness it's the
skill set that's getting him on the
floor
just efficient use of the dribble pump
fake side step
yes jay korver
so far 13 bench points okay how about
that
are you kidding me basketball he sees
the big he says all right i'm going to
protect with my body make the left hand
that is
tough wow
hero lobs and adebayo smashes it over
divincenzo
excellent i thought it was russell's
turnovers
early in the game that were as
mind-boggling as the late ones big shot
here
wow hero tyler hero
hero maneuvering shot clock at two
crowder the fake
out to hero one to fire three god
he was at uh 30 a game in the regular
season played a little bit more in game
two
shot clock at four lost by lopez hold on
to your hands here comes butler
needs help the rest of the supporting
cast they've got to knock down shots
to relieve the pressure off of him he's
four for six from the field the rest is
one for ten
as butler prickly goes down the floor
[Applause]
tyler hero gets to the rim and banks it
home
the heat trying to put away the pesky
bucks dragach floats it up autobio
rebound back out hero
hero dragach inside adebayo
it back out hero for three bang whoever
said a hero ain't nothing but a sandwich
is a liar
he's a knock down shooter and put his
team in position
tyler hero for three puts it in hero
does it again
butler throws it hiro tries again three
pointers up that's good
harrow does it again middleton catch and
fires
tyler hero olynyk early release and
floats in for two
and miami has come back to tie after
being down by
13. hero
evangenzo there picked up by matthews
floater away
and good for tyler hero just don't think
tyler hero is a three-point shooter this
is a guy that could take the ball off
the bounce here
tyler hero this is a three
corey j crowder puts it down
adebayo
here on the passing side hero to
iguodala
timeout milwaukee heat backed by eight
trying to win the series we step aside
on tnt
the bucks who trail by five
approaching seven hiro floats it adebayo
jackhammers it in
shot clock at six puts one up
finished and then takes the shot to the
head the concentration
and the usage of the left hand tyler
hero
putting on a shield did a lot of work
during the shutdown with his trainer
drew hanlon trying to get more shifty
with the ball certainly showing out of
bio and one
miami looking like they're playing a
little faster here definitely
iguodala open side pocket three butter
somebody's got a light of fire so leave
it to the dragon tyler hero
the pitch out to andre iguodala but
druggage got him going now his team is
following
this game mark 1 for 10 and trailed
8-zip
but they are not going away this is a
tough competitive bunch for miami
in a blink they can take the lead butler
inside
count it in one becoming aggressive
picking up the pace now the rest of his
teams are following
look at the way they sprint hero's gonna
command some attention at the
three-point line
you're trailing cutter the guy butler
with the offensive care i'm back out to
hero
heat leading by three wide open jake
crowder bingo
tatum off the front rim
miami running they got a four on three
hero little euro step
lefty finished by the rookie off glass
rookie the way he's played down here in
orlando it feels like
that's going to change in the future for
him in terms of postseason awards that
is a big time move by
hero for three yes this guy
right back at him in the lead is down to
two crowd or a wide open three
shot won't go tip back out tyler hero
now tys gets into the picture
lobs it in and out of bio throws it down
right
the future's bright for this young man
tatum thought he was fouled crowder with
the strip
hero stops three-pointer straight on
knocks it down
tyler hero lighting it up 11 points here
in the second quarter
well good strip by crowder advances it
to hero and then just the pull-up three
is
pure
mark is smart all over hero shoots right
in his face knocks it down
tyler hero 15 points here in the first
half
in just 12 minutes better offense one on
one
elevates i call that hero ball
and jones back out to hero new 14 hero
drives into the lane running layup
wild shot rolls around and drops in
it just expressed so much frustration
that in the case of yet another black
woman in this country
there was no charges brought but rather
only a charge for endangering
her neighbors hill a veteran he's been
in the league for seven years he came
over in the
[ __ ] j crowder trade but has hardly
played
played a little bit in the bubble as
tyler hiro banks at home 31-28 heat with
a three-point advantage hero
lost it got it back turns shoots and
scores
tyler hero 11 points in nine minutes and
he forces brad stevens to call timeout
no fear whatsoever
well he comes off to score every time
picks up the loose ball
still things shot guys low shooting
percentages low score is it more of good
defense or
just guys aren't knocking down shots is
adebayo with a high percentage shot
there he's averaging almost eight
rebounds a game in the series
and banks that one beautifully and they
ran a double flare on that one from the
side out
tyler hero again tyler hero from
downtown
he's got 18 points to lead all scores
good players you're not expecting it to
be easy all the way through we just need
our best quarter
in this quarter they have been able to
break the zone a little bit more in the
second half
what do you do with that maybe we go man
we'll see all right thank you so much
eric back to you mike
all right thank you rachel and reinhard
kitten leads all players
in the playoffs in minutes per game at
40 per game
hiro fires away puts it in tyler harrow
drills another three
hero with seven to shoot hiro
long three-pointer bang tyler hero
from way downtown wow
83 points on 13 of 19 from the field
at this time out they have to give him
an honorary first team all rookie
i want him brought out to half court and
given first team all rookie
duncan robinson the rebound
tyler hero connects on a three hero his
first three-pointer of the game just his
second field goal but it brings miami
back within nine
oh you need to say he's a stud thank you
so much brad back to you mike
all right rachel tyler hero bank shot is
good what a difficult
going left within the right hand floats
it off the glass
i thought he was really good tonight
particularly in the second half
[Applause]
tyler hero connects on a two-pointer but
every time canner comes in
the whole thing for miami is put him in
pick and rolls
[ __ ] dolla gets inside and throws it
down
get an easy one good read on that steal
and good bucket duncan robinson wastes
no time
fires away and hits the three-pointer
his second of the game the guards and
they're
either finding people or like on that
one tatum got right to the rim
hiro with a nice floater of his own
tyler hill with six points off the bench
miami's shooting 58 percent from the
field
out of bio goes down the lane
[Applause]
from
and just because good basketball you
stay at home on the shooters and
bam impacts the game he's done this
entire series
diving to the cup they're now 12 of 26
from three-point range they try the
alley up broken up out of buyer right
there to pick it up
good reaction by robinson to deflect it
hiro the drive
layup backshot is good response by the
heat
the deflection and then tyler hiro
the blow-by taking the contact
and finishing anyway